I'm Sandra Smith I'm Bret Baier I means
lay your heart and this is the Fox News
rundown
Friday April 17 2020 I'm Chris Foster
president Trump wants to get the economy
moving again Fox News Sunday host Chris
Wallace says it's not really his
decision in the end the economy is the
decision of million of individual
consumers and customers and nobody's
going to tell them what to do they're
gonna decide what they wanted to I'm
Dave Anthony many of us are only
shopping online these days or in grocery
stores with so many others closed what
happens when those orders are lifted I
believe a lot of them are never going to
open again or certainly they'll be much
smaller than they were before the
Colonna virus hit head I'm Tammy Bruce
I've got the final word on the Fox News
rundown
as we end a fourth week under federal
guidelines for dealing with coronavirus
President Trump says it's time to start
looking ahead based on the latest data
our team of experts now agrees that we
can begin the next front in our war
which we're calling opening up America
again and that's what we're doing we're
opening up our country and we have to do
that America wants to be open and
Americans want to be open the president
has a lot to juggle making what he's
called the most important decisions of
his time in office balancing concerns
about lives and livelihoods and
increasingly perhaps the politics of it
all I think it's become a political
football chris wallace is the host of
Fox News Sunday the difference is this
has real immediate real life
implications it has tremendous
implications for public health it has
tremendous implications for the economy
and the millions of people who have lost
their jobs so it's a political football
but as opposed to some of those which
you know we we talk about for years and
obviously they have real-world effects
but but nothing seems to happen
when when the president first of all
he's not going to open anything he's
going to really guide lines and then
governors and mayor's will decide
whether to reopen and even ultimately
it's going to be up to the individual
companies governor isn't going to order
you know the Acne hardware company to
open it's going to be up to the owners
of the company whether to open and the
employees whether to go back or to go to
customers to go to a restaurant that's
gonna have the you know a hugely
important thing and the most interest in
development I saw was that the president
was talking to the leaders of various
sectors and when he talked to the
leaders of the financial and banking
industries they really pushed back on
him and they said two things one we need
a lot more testing than we've had we've
got three million tests so far what does
a lot it sounds like an enormous number
but they were talking about needing a
million tests a day to have a much
better sense just how prevalent the the
virus is in American society and
two companies are saying we want
protections liability protection so if
we say the Act
Acme hardware company we're gonna send
our employees back to work and there's a
spike and they start to get the virus
that they can't then sue their employers
and say you know you ordered us back to
work and we got sick in the end and it's
not President Trump it's not even
governor's it's us that are gonna decide
when this gets reopened if we're gonna
go and sit in a restaurant sit at a bar
if there ever conference again go to a
concert and if we don't feel safe we're
not gonna do that and somebody's gonna
have to step up and make that a reality
well I don't know that you can anybody
step up and make it a reality I mean I
mean I was talking with my wife about
this and I was saying you know
particularly on discretionary things
ultimately if you have to go back to
work or you have to go to the grocery
store you do but you know nobody has to
go to a restaurant restaurant has to be
open but but the customers don't have to
come before my wife and I are I guess is
you and and your significant other would
do that you're gonna have a long hard
talk you know is it worth going to a
restaurant and having somebody even in
with masks and gloves serve me food and
be you know within six or eight feet of
somebody even if there's plexiglass
between us and you know why do I want to
do that anyway it doesn't sound like
much fun how do you you know how do you
get in the first time you get on an
airplane
after all this are you gonna feel about
it so and particularly if it's not an
absolutely must work thing but it's you
know something more discretionary
especially now when you've got telework
and zoom and all of these connections
that we have you're exactly right in the
end the economy and will go to its door
and buy things in the end the economy is
the decision of millions of individual
consumers and customers and nobody's
going to tell them what to do they're
gonna decide what they wanted it since
we talked last week Joe Biden has all
the big endorsements now he got Bernie
Monday Barack Obama on Tuesday Elizabeth
Warren it wasn't long ago that the
headlines were Dems in disarray Dems in
disarray and now they seem very much in
array earlier than we
two guests a couple of months ago oh
absolutely you know think back I mean
except for when Barack Obama was running
for re-election in 2012 the party has
not been this United really since 2004
and John Kerry because if you remember
Obama and Clinton in 2008 Clinton and
Sanders in 2016 you know it went by into
June even July I mean there were some
questions Hillary Clinton didn't release
her delegates and you know formally
support Barack Obama until the
convention in Denver in 2008 so this is
you know in a situation where there are
a lot of disadvantages for Joe Biden
obviously that he's stuck in his
basement of his home in Delaware and
can't go out in campaign and can't
excite people this is an advantage that
here we are in the very beginning of
April and the party is really united
Elizabeth Warren Barack Obama Bernie
Sanders is really united behind him now
you know he's it tough to mobilize
support is tough to raise money in the
current world we're living in
with the particularly money with
people's economic futures so when
certain having said that I do think that
Donald Trump is a huge organizing
principle for for Democrats and for Joe
Biden and you know my guess is once we
get to Labor Day that and and hopefully
by then the cobia virus is not quite as
clear and present danger as it seems to
be now that that people this will be a
fair and evenly fought election between
the President Joe Biden I hope so
president Trump has been making a lot of
noise against moves for more mail now
owning voting by mail just in case there
are spikes in certain areas I'm not
really sure what his problem with it is
I don't know that there's evidence that
Democrats vote more would vote more by
mail than Republicans would know it's
it's odd I mean he's he's saying that
you know it lends itself to corruption
it lends himself to cheating abuse and
there certainly have been cases of that
but there been cases of Republicans
doing it and in fact
a lot of Republicans at the same time
that he was talking about it in North
Carolina the GOP was running a big you
know get absentee ballot campaign to try
to get you know people to vote that way
you know I mean generally speaking
people most people both parties have
generally favored early balloting
absentee balloting mail-in balloting
making it easier for people to vote and
I don't think there's really much of a
of a record documentary record that
shows that Democrats are advantaged by
mailing balloting more than then
Republicans are but you know and as I
say there are a lot of local candidates
Republican candidates who were all
formed mailing balloting Act the
President did it himself when he voted
in Florida
yeah members of the military overseas
vote by mail and nobody seems to be
worried about fraud there Stacey Abrams
from Georgia is all but campaigning to
be Biden's running mate Elizabeth Warren
was asked she said yes I would say yes
if it was offered any thoughts on who
helps him politically well I think two
things one you know you he's committed
to a woman now some people are saying
well he you know in this crisis he
doesn't need a woman but that's
something kind of insulting about that
saying well now the stakes are really
important we can't afford to have a
woman I don't think that will go over
very well you know you would first of
all the question of who the Vice
President is we always love to play it
because it's always an open question we
the media it always is vastly overstated
in terms of its importance if you're
your vice presidential running mate can
get you one state that's a big deal and
that would argue for somebody like
Gretchen Whitmer a mission again because
of the fact that that's a key swing
state that that Trump was able to take
from the Democrats additionally a
democratic state in 2016 and Republicans
really need emma-crats rather really
need to get it back having said that I
do think that with this crisis you're
you know when she's new on the scene I
mean I think she just became a governor
at the start of this year you need her I
guess that maybe we started 2019
you really I think because of this
crisis are going to need somebody with a
lot of hands on government experience
which I think would argue less for a
Whitmer and less frankly for a Stacey
Abrams and more for an Elizabeth Warren
or a baby clover jar or Kamala Harris in
other words somebody who's been in
public life a little bit longer and has
one of Phi DS you know particularly with
would Biden who is 77 years old I think
you really the one test I think for the
vice president that he picks is you know
could they can you really see them as a
president on the second day of that
administration real quick Chris
president Trump run after you again and
Fox in general the other day he was
displeased by a line of questioning did
he really yeah he didn't hear I don't
even remember what the line of
questioning was but it was pretty
innocuous as I recall and I'm sure that
there are some Fox viewers and listeners
of this radio show in this podcast that
take issue with sometimes with lines of
questioning that you might take or Bret
Baier might take or somebody on the news
side what do you say to them those Wells
and those listeners yes I think he
specifically was referring to the fact
that I was asking people about the big
story in The New York Times that seemed
to document pretty pretty well that the
president despite some warnings from
people in his administration was slowed
to issue the guidelines on social
distancing and stay at home until
mid-march you know what I would say is
watch the interviews I do with Democrats
I I'm I'm a tough interviewer and and I
think I'm known in the viewing community
that way and I know I'm known in the
political community that way I know that
Mitch McConnell is that I'm the toughest
Sunday show winner if you were any
choices to his new public incentives
don't think that you're going on Fox if
you're with Chris Wallace you're gonna
get an easy interview but I've known
that way in the Democratic community as
well and you know I would just say to
anybody who thinks that maybe I'm a
closet liberal or a closeted Democrat
just go on YouTube we've got some time
today Google and watch the interview I
did with James Comey a couple of months
ago when the the
by what the Inspector General report
came out about abuses with FISA you know
I'm as somebody once asked Vince
Lombardi the legendary football coach
does he discriminate against the players
like he's tougher on the the grunts than
he is on the stars and that this one
player said no he's a he treats us all
like dogs and that's the way I feel I'm
that I'm the cop on the beat and I wield
the nightstick and I try to keep
everybody honest all right Chris Wallace
according to the president even worse
than sleepy-eyed Chuck Todd Chris thanks
for coming out
all right stay safe have a good day
thanks Chris you bet thank you this is
Tammy Bruce with your fox news
commentary coming up we all want this
nightmare to be over from the many of us
stuck at home to the president to the
governors will be in charge of lifting
the coronavirus orders in this reopening
we could lose all the progress we made
in one week if we do it wrong andrew
Cuomo State New York has been hit
hardest by far more than a third of all
the US cases so he is not yet ready to
reopen the closed down policies will be
extended in coordination with other
states to May 15th he's talking about
other states in the New York Region
which is going to add to the pain in the
retail industry with so many stores
closed in March US retail sales plunged
almost 9% that's the biggest drop on
record and the shutdowns didn't even
happen till later in the month
clothing sales were cut in half from
February in the one hand this is very a
very deep decline in retail sales on the
other hand it's totally expected many of
these stores are shuttered by law
Jerry Storch runs his own company's
torch advisors but he's been in the
business a long time he was once the CEO
of Toys R Us he also ran Hudson Bay
which owns Saks and he was a target
vice-chairman to me I'm actually
optimistic about it it shows they're
still still life out there and it also
shows people are doing what we've asked
them to do in terms of sheltering at
home and you can see that in the sales
patterns obviously people if they're
doing shopping
unless it's grocery they're doing it
from home and a lot of times even at
home they're doing the online and then
go into the store and picking it up
obviously online sales have picked up
over the years this probably puts it may
be over the top yeah I think I think
this I thought I say this is this is you
know a rapid acceleration of trends that
existed before
so you see ecommerce growing even more
rapidly because people of course feel
safer getting a package delivered than
going to it to a store and and also you
can buy anything on e-commerce still you
know not just necessities so this is a
big boost recon ecommerce and some of
that is definitely going to stick and
this is also a big problem for for the
malls which have been in decline for
some time and for and for apparel stores
because of apparel you know clothing is
not a necessity and people clearly are
not buying that even online in big
numbers during this period yeah I mean
people are working from home and their
pajamas I mean who's buying anything
formal who's buying anything suits and
all that kind of stuff nobody needs it
and nobody knows for how long so a store
like Macy's or a clothing store what do
they do well they you know they have to
rely heavily on the new e-commerce arms
and some of them built good ecommerce
arms some didn't so Macy's in Nordstrom
have done a pretty good job of building
strong e-commerce businesses having said
that you're looking at twenty to thirty
percent of their business before this
hit and and frankly I don't think it's
even growing in terms of absolute scale
is probably shrinking in this market but
that's all they have left and they're
bricks and mortar or shredder then you
have other other stores like at JCPenney
who never really did get off the mark on
growing a strong e-commerce business and
so not only are all their stores closed
but they don't really have a strong
ecommerce leg to live on but that's all
there is and that's what they need to do
JCPenney obviously we had Sears which
was already in a huge decline with Kmart
maybe going away
how many of these kinds of stores are
never gonna come back I believe a lot of
them are never going to open again or
certainly they'll be much smaller than
they wore before the coronavirus hit in
the United States we probably have two
to three times the retail square footage
per capita
that we really need in this country and
so you saw that being reflected in
constant store closings that's going to
accelerate dramatically many of these
companies you know even if they get
handed a lifeline during the coronavirus
crisis because nobody wants to put an
American icon out of business right now
they'll run into severe problems next
year or the year after so they're all a
lot of them are out there talking their
lenders their restructure in their debt
pennies is reportedly you know trying to
decide whether to go chapter 11 or not
but they're certainly going to need to
restructure their debt Neiman Marcus is
highly leveraged Macy's and and Jays and
Nordstrom and Kohl's all have covenant
issues coming up on their debt so
they're all going to have to renegotiate
with their banks but on the other end it
doesn't look that much brighter for them
the problem is they were losing before
and so they end up in a more leveraged
situation coming out of this it only
makes it that much more bleak especially
with consumers learning that they really
can get along without them
you know we talked a lot of people
talked going into even this year way
before the corona crisis ever emerged do
we really need a department store
anymore you had ecommerce up of course
as we've discussed so Amazon is just
just on fire it's phenomenal how how
strong they are in this in this in this
situation the situation and they were up
20% year before this so just imagine
mass merchants like Walmart and Target
and Costco have been gobbling up share
for a long time and they're grabbing
even more right now because their stores
are open because they sell necessities
too during this period the pharmacies
are doing well because of course they
sell necessities the grocery stores and
the liquor stores are thriving because
of course people are eating and drinking
trust me at home and so that's growing a
lot this is this for some of them they
were they were kind of taking it on the
chin a little bit
as people were eating out more now
that's shifted back to the grocery
stores so this is maybe some help to
grocery stores in the future and of
course same Depot coupon Lowe's
buildings apply people they are up your
rear even in March because again they
sell necessities things that you need
for your home things to keep your home
safe and clean and and working so so
they're doing great so these were all
the winners before meanwhile the losers
this simply accelerates the pattern
you know with department stores
declining clothing declining across the
board too much bricks and mortar right
now way too much and the pace of tore
closings will double or triple as we get
into next spring you brought up malls
they've had a lot of hard times in the
last couple of years with the rise in
e-commerce and department stores closing
so if malls wind malls can reopen how
many can survive and how do they survive
how much more will they have to shift
toward entertainment well they were
already making a big push there and some
of the best operators like life Simon
for example who runs runs a great great
operation they were already making this
shift the problem we have now is is
something they can't control first of
all many of their tenants you know can't
pay their rent so that's a big problem
but sake yeah secondly the customers
afraid to go out in public so it's not
worth you know taking that kind of
personal risk to most people to go to a
mall just for you know for discretionary
shopping it feels like a Dahlia Terre
frivolous action in times like these and
it's going to seem like that until one
of two things happen either we have a
vaccine which is over a year away
everyone says or until there really is
enough comprehensive mass testing that
people feel safe and I don't think there
are even any plans to test on that kind
of scale so I believe traffic at malls
is going to be greatly suppressed for at
least a year which is a long time so
many of these models that B and C malls
that were already in trouble they're
going to close you mention rent how do
companies and landlords in the retail
business hang on
if stores don't pay how long can they
last and keep things going it's a big
problem because they tend to be very
mall owners tend to be highly leveraged
so they they basically have sold those
rent strings if you will right to it as
they have mortgaged their property so so
they have a mortgage to pay on the
property on the other end so it's not
like they can just say oh I get it it's
so so sad that you're closed you don't
have to pay your rent if you are a
you know an individual and you see great
stories about about owners of individual
properties saying that to their tenants
forget about it don't pay right now you
don't need to that's great
but if you're a big developer and you've
already leveraged these properties and
you have mortgages due on the other end
what do you do when your tenants aren't
paying you so this can create a severe
distress in the commercial mortgage
market down the line from the retail
market so you have you have a need for
sort of tri-party negotiations between
the retail tenants the landlords and the
landlord's creditors who can't just say
it's okay don't pay me they they expect
those payments so there's a big problem
here that has to be worked out and it's
big it's not small this is a big number
in the scope of the US economy let's
talk about the small little stores if
people call them the mom and pops and
main streets across America they
probably don't have big e-commerce
operations what do they do and how many
of them might not make it well you know
fortunately a lot of them are able to
get help from the government most of the
big retailers are too large
under the current programs to get
federal assistance so many of the
smaller retailers can and that will give
them some opportunity to make it make
their way forward now those who a week
before I you know they're not going to
survive regardless those who are strong
before they're probably able to come out
of this thanks to prompt action by the
administration and by Congress on
passing support for these for these for
these businesses but even then when the
gartner in the you know there's not
enough money in the world when the world
finally reopens we're going to have a
problem with the willingness of the
consumer with the consumer psychic ones
to go out there and to mingle the way
that they used to unless we have a
vaccine or much more comprehensive
testing than what we have in place and
then what we're even planning is Amazon
going to emerge now as the clear number
one or Walmart still with them I
wouldn't I wouldn't sell Walmart it's
interesting that both stocks Walmart and
Amazon hit their all-time highs earlier
this week on the on the stock exchange
so so they're there they're doing both
doing great Walmart is doing fantastic
in groceries
they're the largest
oh sure in the US and Amazon has not
cracked that nut
I think Amazon made a you strategic
error buying Whole Foods it was the
wrong grocer they should have bought a
Kroger or Albertsons or someone more
omnipresent than Whole Foods and someone
who doesn't have quite that high-end
positioning and so Amazon really still
is not a not a major player in the
grocery industry and Walmart is the
leader and so they're able to leverage
that across the whole world of retail
and e-commerce so Walmart's by far the
largest grocer in the country a large
part of their e-commerce business is
grocery both delivery and pickup at the
store I mean while Amazon of course is
doing great they are the king and queen
of the internet you know they are so
much larger than anyone else is not even
close so when people talk about Walmart
versus Amazon Amazon is 10 times Walmart
size in e-commerce sales much has been
made during this corona virus nightmare
and rightly so about the heroics of
doctors and nurses and EMTs and all the
other medical workers on the front lines
putting themselves at risk you know who
else is those who work in grocery stores
pharmacies and other retailers still
open and considered essential to
checkouts in the clerk's and the people
that are really and a number of those
people have become infected so we want
to thank them and a shout out to them
that was President Trump the other day
now these employees are not typically
making a lot of money some get minimum
wage you're not much more doing what are
considered low pay jobs
what are these stores doing for them
first of all most of them have given
them you know raises have given them
extra pay for this period so that's a
that's a good thing but but it's not
enough and secondly what you can do
turns pay to pay a lot of attention to
their their welfare make sure they have
the right protective equipment the right
education on how to keep themselves safe
the right health care and also create an
environment where when they're feeling
sick it's okay to raise your hand and
not come to work and so so it's from
those daily communications where your
workers that you can let them know that
you do care about them even as they do
get a nice bump and pay that would be
very helpful to them during a time when
the economy is troubled
jerry Storch CEO for Storch advisors we
really appreciate you joining us thank
you
thank you have a nice day
[Music]
from the Fox News podcasts Network
download and listen to the untold story
with Martha McCallum the host of the
story on Fox News Channel sits down with
major newsmakers each week to get their
untold stories subscribe and listen now
by going to Fox News podcasts dot-com
subscribe to this podcast at Fox News
podcasts com and now some good news with
Tanya J powers you may not have ever
envisioned a world in which we needed to
be reminded to put on clothes before
going outside but here we are
the Taneytown Maryland police department
is telling people to do just that with a
recent Facebook post it says quote
please remember to put pants on before
leaving the house to check your mailbox
you know who you are this is your final
warning so far the post has been shared
more than 7,000 times and has more than
2,800 likes it's not the first time the
department has used humor and posts to
its 11,000 followers the department also
recently urged people to stay indoors
using the lyrics to baby shark and they
also posted a tiger King meme Tonya J
powers Fox News
[Music]
it's time for your Fox News commentary
what's on your mind Americans have been
doing a fantastic job
following the coronavirus guidance of
the president their governors and
perhaps also their local leaders when it
comes to social distancing and taking
precautions not just for ourselves and
for our own health but for those around
us yet lo and behold certain politicians
have mistaken our willingness to adhere
to social distancing and stay-at-home
guidelines as a signal that they can do
whatever they please we now see various
mayors and governors using this time of
crisis to issue extraordinary and as
many see it unconstitutional orders in
the name of Public Health and Safety
during this time of pandemic we are
adults we understand the suggestions
we've been given proven by the
overwhelming adherence to the federal
guidelines in the midst of this crisis
we also know when orders are
inappropriate at the very least and
unconstitutional abuses of power at the
worst people reacted with some shock
when video from Italy revealed a lone
jogger along an empty beach being chased
by a police officer but it would be
wrong to dismiss that as unique European
totalitarianism other shocking video has
alarmed the public including the scene
of 10 Philadelphia police officers
dragging a passenger off a bus for not
wearing a face mask as noted by the
National Review which also tells us of a
scene in Brighton Colorado with cops
handcuffing a father in front of his
family for playing t-ball with his
daughter in an empty park getting a
great deal of attention appropriately in
the follies of governor's as little
tyrants is Michigan's Gretchen Whitmer
Tucker Carlson of Fox News said many
hospitals in Michigan are now
discharging more coronavirus patients
than they're admitting in fact an
emergency hospital under construction
outside Detroit has slashed its bed
count from 1,000 to 250 why the expected
number of patients failed to arrive he
then noted that Miz Whitmer has not only
not acknowledged this but she's doubling
down on her efforts to control the
movement and freedom of the people of
Michigan quote last week Whitmer ban
all gatherings anywhere for any reason
of any size including in people's
private homes as if she is allowed to do
that mr. Carlson said she has also
banned people from traveling between
their own homes part of her announcement
of the increasing crackdown included
quote big-box stores will also have to
close areas of the store that are
dedicated to things like carpeting or
flooring furniture garden centers plant
nurseries or paint if you're not buying
food or medicine or other essential
items you shouldn't be going to the
store
how is purchasing paint or gardening
tools or seeds to plant your own food
during a pandemic an essential who gets
to decide of what becomes a question of
all of us when it comes to how we shop
and what we deem is essential for our
own lives during a crisis few of us
believe politicians know what's best in
that case it is our responsibility as
responsible citizens to implement
sensible and productive efforts such as
the federal coronavirus guidelines to
slow and eventually stop this pandemic
and we're doing exactly that but what we
will not agree to is the torching of the
US Constitution or the destruction of
the country by people who seem drunk on
unconstitutional power they imagine is
afforded to them in a crisis this is
Tammy Bruce
you've been listening to the FoxNews
rundown and stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at FoxNews
podcasts calm and for up-to-the-minute
news go to Fox news.com love Fox News
click the subscribe button to get more
of the news and opinion you trust and
click the FoxNews rundown playlist for
the latest episodes